nous avons aussi je vous le redis un
devoir de lucidité il existe dans
certaines mosquées comme sur certains
sites internet se réclamant de l'islam
un discours qu'il faut qualifier pour ce
qu'il est un discours secteur un
discours d' enfermement communautariste
un discours aussi d'intimidation qui
peut à juste titre inquiéter les
français musulmans ou non musulmans
ce discours sectaire je le redis comme
je les ai toujours dit solennellement
devant vous fait beaucoup de mal à
l'islam républicain et paisible que
plusieurs millions de nos concitoyens
pratique en tentant de faire croire aux
autres français qu'ils représentent la
réalité de votre religion l'islam dans
la république ne peut pas être une
revendication politique
il ne peut pas être un instrument de
lutte contre la république
l'islam c'est une fois c'est un livre ce
sont des lieux de culte des pratiques
cultuelles c'est une religion
ce sont aussi des savants c'est de la
littérature c'est une architecture c'est
une langue comme le latin était la
langue de l'église est une source
infinie de richesses pour l'humanité
dans sa radicalité le discours de death
rejoint ici celui des pamphlétaires anti
musulmans puisque les uns et les autres
conçoivent l'islam comme une idéologie
de haine ennemis de toute forme de
civilisation
je tiens à le redire ici avec la plus
grande netteté
il n'y a pas il n'y a jamais de
fondamentalisme pacifique
il n'y a pas de salafisme anodin il n'ya
pas d'intégrisme modéré dès que l'on
professe le rejet de la république
on prépare les esprits à ce qui vient
immédiatement ensuite l'apologie de la
violence et peut-être de la haine